kind of like the fact that basil kind of  threw himself out there maybe bezos is  sitting there saying [ __ ] i'm not as  loved as musk is yeah because i'm  playing it so damn safe you know what  i'm the new rebel and i'm the new guy  you know what screw this [ __ ] of trying  to be the mr nice guy worth 300 billion  dollars and you know what forget about  it i'm in the game of recreating myself  i'm about to show you guys what i'm  really all about i'ma push my weight as  well i hope that  backbone comes out but you're just  hoping when that backbone comes up  people are not bought on the back end or  afraid of all these other fears that  people are going to bring who knows  what's going to end up happening